il donnait confiance car on leur avait
maintes fois répété la culture c'est ce
qui reste quand on a tout oublié
et pour faîtier d'oublier alors là il
était doué la configuration
excessivement passoire euse de leur
cerveau leur permettait d'oublier les
choses à des vitesses proprement
vertigineuse de sorte qu'ils accédaient
c'était sûr au plus haut sommet de la
culture si je disais que si on voulait
perfectionner le système
il n'était pas nécessaire d'attendre de
savoir des choses pour les ouvriers
après il était beaucoup plus intéressant
au compteur d'oublier des choses avant
de les avoir appris ce qui améliorerait
notablement le rendement culturel vous
en conviennent
ce qu'il fallait d'abord c'était donc
apprendre à ne pas attendre ce qu'il
fallait ensuite c'était oublier au plus
vite est un continent les jauges de par
mégarde il aurait pu avoir pour les
aider à se débarrasser de tout ce qu'il
ne fallait pas savoir les shadoks avait
créé lentilles mémoire c'était un grand
machin à base des mécaniques subtil
quelques poubelles à tiroirs concasseur
de connaissances broyeur à savoir etc
on le promener de fonnière en chaumières
et il récupère est tout ce que les
shadoks pour leur hygiène culturelles
étaient obligés d'oublier qu'en par
maladresse paraissent une alternance le
chat d'oc dans un moment d'oubli en
quelque sorte se souvenait de quelque
chose quand il est moins appliqués
tartas il lui disait papa savoir et leur
mémoire jeter sa danse est le reste du
temps ils vivaient dans les champs il
ruminait de la mathématique et de la
cybernétique de la logique formelle et
du calcul différentiel la civilisation
sadok grâce à ces soins allait contre
nancy mémoire grandissait en âge et en
vigueur ce n'est que beaucoup plus tard
qu'il prit le nom d'ordinateur